During WWII, thousands of Japanese pilots
made the ultimate sacrifice for their country
by becoming, essentially, flying suicide bombers.
But what was it that made these men so willing
to lay down their lives in such a way?
Were they really bright eyed volunteers eager
to sacrifice themselves for the greater good,
as the war time propaganda stated, or were
they forced into it?
Also, why exactly did the Japanese military
resort to such a tactic in the first place?
For starters, the Japanese military brass
were desperate.
The enemy had them outgunned, out-manned,
and possessed certain critical technologies
that Japan didn’t have.
To illustrate how dire things were, going
back to 1942, in a single day in June of that
year Japan lost more airmen than they had
managed to train in an entire year just before
the war.
Adequately training new pilots fast enough
simply wasn’t feasible.
This resulted in sending out relatively inexperienced
pilots in outdated aircraft.
There was a reason the Battle of the Philippine
Sea in June of 1944 became nicknamed “The
Great Marianas Turkey Shoot” by the Allies.
Further, death before defeat was firmly ingrained
in the Japanese military culture at the time.
In Emiko Ohnuki-Tierney’s work, Kamikaze
Diaries (accounts by the so-called “student
soldiers” of Japan from their writings during
the war- many of the prospective kamikaze
volunteers were these “boy-pilots”), it
stated one of the first things student soldiers
learned was
to use his toe to pull the trigger [of his
rifle] while pointing the gun precisely at
a certain point under his chin so that the
bullet would kill him instantly.
He was supposed to use this technique if he
was trapped in a cave or in a trench surrounded
by the enemy.
If he did not kill himself but tried to escape,
he might be shot from behind, because his
superiors and some comrades believed in the
state dictum that one must never be captured
by the enemy.
This brings us to the Tokubetsu Kōgekitai
(literally, “Special Attack Unit”), members
of which are commonly called “kamikazes”.
Though the idea of sending pilots on one-way
suicide missions is largely attributed to
one, Capt. Motoharu Okamura, reports of Japanese
pilots intentionally crashing their planes
into the enemy, often when damaged too much
to return to base, weren’t unheard of prior
to the start of the suicide pilot initiative
in 1944.
However, it was Capt. Motoharu Okamura who
is largely believed to have been the first
high-ranking Japanese officer to propose the
idea as a preplanned tactic.
Famously stating:
In our present situation I firmly believe
that the only way to swing the war in our
favor is to resort to crash-dive attacks with
our planes.
There is no other way.
There will be more than enough volunteers
for this chance to save our country, and I
would like to command such an operation.
Provide me with 300 planes and I will turn
the tide of war.
That said, it was not Okamura, but then Vice-Admiral
of the Japanese Navy, Takijiro Onishi who
is credited with creating the first squadron
of kamikaze pilots.
Onishi reportedly approached his superiors
to ask to create a suicide squad and was granted
permission on one condition, he was only allowed
to recruit volunteers.
Determined to make his suicide squads a reality,
Onishi personally made the very first announcement
requesting volunteers for the “special attack
force” at Mabalacat Air Base.
All 23 pilots asked to join ultimately volunteered.
From here, reports of the day are that many
more pilots than there were planes eagerly
signed up (supposedly so many that they outnumbered
the available planes 3 to 1).
As Captain Motoharu Okamura stated, “There
were so many volunteers for suicide missions
that he referred to them as a swarm of bees…
Bees die after they have stung.”
(In truth, bees do not usually die after they
sting things.
This generally only happens when they sting
humans, as their stingers get stuck in our
fleshy skin.
This is not the case when they sting many
other animals.)
However, the official story of droves of zealous
volunteers clamoring to sign up has been questioned
by many historians, particularly with firsthand
accounts from actual pilots popping up since,
painting a decidedly less patriotic or eager
tone.
Imperial Japanese Navy Gekitsui-O (flying
ace), Saburo Sakai, who had at least 28 victories
ranking him fourth for the war for Japan,
including shooting down or severely damaging
over 60 Allied planes, stated in an interview,
“Even now, many faces of my students come
up when I close my eyes.
So many students are gone.
Why did headquarters continue such silly attacks
for ten months!
Fools! … all those men lied that all men
volunteered for kamikaze units.
They lied!”
Further, many of the “boy-soldiers” who
ended up becoming kamikaze pilots were brutally
treated during their training, to the point
that, based on firsthand accounts from the
trainees, many lost any sense of patriotism.
For instance, Irokawa Daikichi stated he was
“struck on the face so hard and frequently
that [his] face was no longer recognizable…
I was hit so hard that I could no longer see
and fell on the floor.
The minute I got up, I was hit again by a
club…”
Officially, the purpose for this extremely
brutal “training” was to instill in the
soldiers a “fighting spirit”.
Hayashi Ichizo went on to say,
It is easy to talk about death in the abstract,
as the ancient philosophers discussed.
But it is real death I fear, and I don’t
know if I can overcome the fear.
Even for a short life, there are many memories.
For someone who had a good life, it is very
difficult to part with it.
But I reached a point of no return.
I must plunge into an enemy vessel.
To be honest, I cannot say that the wish to
die for the emperor is genuine, coming from
my heart.
However, it is decided for me that I die for
the emperor.
These were sentiments echoed by Lieutenant
Yukio Seki, who commanded the first squadron
of 23: “Japan’s future is bleak if it
is forced to kill one of its best pilots…
I am not going on this mission for the Emperor
or for the Empire…
I am going because I was ordered to.”
While there certainly were those who were
willing to volunteer to die for emperor and
country, and many more willing to die in this
way simply because they felt, somewhat correctly,
that they were the last line of defense to
protect their families and friends at home,
in truth many seem to have simply been pressured
into it.
So what tactics were specifically used to
convince the volunteers?
As noted in Mako Sasaki’s paper, Who Became
Kamikaze Pilots, and How Did They Feel Towards
Their Suicide Mission, published in The Concord
Review, some men were recruited to the program
by way of a simple questionnaire.
The questionnaire comprised of a single multi-choice
question that asked: “Do you desire earnestly/wish/do
not wish to be involved in kamikaze attacks?”
All the men had to do was circle the statement
they most agreed with.
The kicker being that although the men were
free to say they didn’t want to take part,
they still had to sign their name to it.
As Sasaki points out, the pressure on young
men to do something for their country during
that time was significant, and the threat
of retaliation if you said no was very real,
as was the fear that there would potentially
be retaliation against not only the soldier,
but his family back home.
According to the aforementioned Emiko Ohnuki-Tierney,
in Kamikaze Diaries, other methods of encouraging
men to volunteer included putting them in
a room filled with their peers.
After a lengthy speech on patriotism, it was
asked that anyone who didn’t wish to be
a kamikaze step forward.
As you can imagine, volunteering by default
in this way was extremely effective.
Beyond any loyalty to country and emperor,
few would want to appear so cowardly, or endure
the shame of not being willing to die when
their fellow soldiers were giving their own
lives to protect their homeland, both those
present when volunteers were being asked for
and ultimately those who’d already fulfilled
their suicide missions.
This latter point was frequently written about
in the letters and journals from many of the
volunteers as to why they ultimately chose
to do so.
If you’re wondering what happened to the
few men that said no, according to Emiko,
If a soldier had managed to be courageous
enough not to volunteer, he would have been
consigned to a living hell.
Any soldier who refused would become persona
non grata or be sent to the southern battlefield,
where death was guaranteed.
Some soldiers actually managed to say no,
but their refusal was disregarded.
Kuroda Kenjirō decided not to volunteer,
only to be taken by surprise when he found
his name on the list of volunteers for the
Mitate Navy tokkōtai corps; his superior
had reported proudly that all the members
of his corps had volunteered.
Not all kamikaze pilots died though.
If a pilot’s plane developed a problem en
route or if a suitable target didn’t present
itself, there was nothing stopping him from
returning to base to try again later.
In fact, the manual given to kamikaze pilots
stated: “In the event of poor weather conditions
when you cannot locate the target, or under
other adverse circumstances, you may decide
to return to base.
Don’t be discouraged.
Do not waste your life lightly.”
All that said, in an interview with an ex-kamikaze
pilot named Tadamasa Itatsu, he notes that
some young men were willing to lay down their
lives simply because they genuinely “believed
their actions could save their country from
disaster“.
As Ichizo Hayashi stated in a letter he wrote
in April of 1945, a few days before his death,
“I am pleased to have the honour of having
been chosen as a member of a Special Attack
Force that is on its way into battle, but
I cannot help crying when I think of you,
Mum.
When I reflect on the hopes you had for my
future … I feel so sad that I am going to
die without doing anything to bring you joy.”
This all might leave you wondering how effective
the kamikaze program was for the Japanese.
According to the U.S. Air Force, nearly three
thousand kamikaze attacks took place, managing
to damage 368 ships, sinking 34 of them, while
killing 4,900 navy soldiers and wounding another
4,800, but with only about 14% of attacking
kamikaze pilots managing to hit a ship.
So, in that sense, plane for plane, it was
tragically successful considering the Americans
had radar, superior numbers and planes, and
the kamikaze pilots were often woefully inexperienced.
But on the other hand, perhaps Lieutenant
Commander Iwatani said it best in a March
of 1945 edition of Taiyo magazine,
I cannot predict the outcome of the air battles,
but you will be making a mistake if you should
regard Special Attack operations as normal
methods.
The right way is to attack the enemy with
skill and return to the base with good results.
A plane should be utilized over and over again.
That’s the way to fight a war.
The current thinking is skewed.
Otherwise, you cannot expect to improve air
power.
There will be no progress if flyers continue
to die.
The Japanese also had a group of one manned
torpedo like submarines called kaitens that
were also used for the same purpose as the
kamikaze pilots- essentially, humans were
the guidance system.
These kaitens were just modified torpedoes
that allowed the person inside to control
them.
They also featured a self destruct mechanism
if the person failed in their mission.
This was necessary as there was no way for
the person inside to get out of the torpedo
once sealed in.
Early models did include a mechanism to escape
once the torpedo was aimed correctly, but
not a single soldier seems to have ever used
this feature, so it was quickly abandoned.
Each person who died as a kaiten pilot would
earn their family ¥10000 (about $120 today).
Kaitens were ultimately not very successful
primary because they could not be deployed
very deeply and were stored on the outside
of the submarines.
This isn’t so much a problem for the kaitens
as it was for the submarines carrying them
who would have to stay very near the surface.
This resulted in an average of about eight
submarines carrying kaitens being destroyed
for every two ships destroyed by the kaitens.
Each kaiten was about 50 feet long; could
reach a maximum speed of about 30 miles per
hour; and contained a warhead
at
the nose.